et avec nous gérard vespière fondateurs
du web magazine le monde décrypté et
douglas y est professeur de droit et
spécialiste de sciences politiques
américaines bonsoir messieurs et merci
d'être en direct avec nous douglas y est
une première question pour vous peut-on
parler de fiasco pour les états unis
après cet attentat de jeudi il me
rappelle très soldats américains tuer
même si la majorité des victimes se
trouvent côté afghan
oui le feu le fiasco est global c'est
une retraite mal organisés mal appliquée
on a évacué une trentaine de milliers
des gens la plupart ne sont pas des
américains sont exogènes collaborateurs
mais en a des milliers des gens de plus
ça va tuer pendant quatre ans le proto
ration était notre et maintenant tout le
monde
commerçants des trajets facile pour les
terroristes
très vite et si vous êtes d'accord avec
cela gérard vespière c'est une vacation
mal préparés on peut dire que la
situation a tourné à la catastrophe pour
jo d'athènes on peut parler de deux
premiers gros revers pour lui
je pense que si on prend un peu de recul
et si on se place en début d'année 2022
beaucoup de choses ont changé n'est ce
pas là nous sommes dans les images de
l'émotion à le départ américain
était programmé déjà depuis sept huit
ans depuis 7-8 ans a à partir du moment
où le maximum des troupes avaient
atteint 100 milles à homs ou embarras au
mama pardon et bien tous les ans il y
avait cinq dix vingt mille hommes qui
étaient retirés et on savait que donc
avec les négociations entre 2018 et 2020
avec les talibans est donc washington le
départ et était prévu donc le départ
était acté prévu après combien de temps
pouvait
le pouvoir en place à kaboul résister ça
c'était la grande inconnue et vous savez
donc les états unis ont quand même
beaucoup beaucoup d'équipement en
mobilisant simplement 20% de leurs
principales avions de transport ils ont
réussi qu'on vient de dire a évacué
plusieurs dizaines et pratiquement 100
mille cent mille personnes donc c'est
peu de chose par rapport à la capacité
américaine
toujours difficile à mettre en place
dans de telles circonstances
avec des milliers de personnes avec la
cohue vraiment c'est quelque chose de
très difficile quel que soit le pays a
organisé et pourtant double s y est joe
biden avait avait parlé en mardi dernier
dans l'ain d'un risque croissant d'une
attaque du groupe terroriste dèche c'est
bien ce qui s'est passé comment est ce
que vous vous analysez à cela oui donc
le but de terroristes c'est d'avoir la
fonction c'est une évidence une
spectaculaire et tout le monde
maintenant
forlan est un 6 et il y en
avoir
des modes et ce soit pas même une
actualité pendant l'élection
présidentielle américaine mais
maintenant tous les camarades de du
monde entier sont sur afghanistan donc
c'est une invitation notéris de manquer
des massacres des attentes en
désaccord
sans merci parce que le but c'est
d'attirer attention c'est très
spécifique stratégie de montée en terre
le peur et ça marche très bien mais
après l'évacuation des américains des
collaborateurs
l'interface de la taliban et les
chaussures à différentes maintenant les
ennemis sont acceptables sont des
américaines sur les collaborateurs avec
les américains mais apprécie d'akerys
faut continuer dans cette stratégie il
sera
chien égard à la bataille
gerra vespière la crainte que les états
unis peuvent encore avoir c'est un autre
attentat c'est pour cela que la date
butoir du 31 août ne peut pas être
changé
c'est un des paramètres effectivement
alors le mode opératoire bon et
difficilement
reproductibles maintenant il reste
seulement une très grande attention
portée avec des fouilles individuel
puisque ce sont des combattants donc de
l'état islamique étaient des kamikazes
dont il portait les charges explosives
pour eux sur euh pardon donc à
l'évidence ce screening 7 ce filtre ou
va être mise en place pour éviter que de
tels événements se reproduisent et donc
je crois que comme cela vient d'être dit
il va y avoir en face à face qui a déjà
débuté car la semaine dernière une des
premières entre donc des ch et puis
l'état islamique et les talibans et le
face à face à cet état islamique est
taliban a déjà commencé la semaine
dernière les talibans ont fait sortir à
plusieurs milliers de prisonniers de la
triste célèbre prison apoula chakri et
donc ils ont exécuté un des leaders de
dédit de l'état islamique qui étaient
retenus là dont vous voyez vous déjà les
talibans ont marqué leur territoire et
toutes les deux par contre on à l'ennemi
commun ce sont les chiites ce sont les
hasards à est aussi bien les talibans
que l'état islamique depuis des années
on persécute les chi afghans
ce sont là les liens que l'on peut
trouver entre les taliban et des ch
pardon c'est ce sont là les miens qu'on
peut trouver entre les taliban et des
shsh les uniques les ans que l'on peut
faire entre eux 1 j'ai effectivement un
ennemi commun vis-à-vis des de la
population hazard à
glace oeil etes vous êtes d'accord avec
cette analyse de gérard vespière sûr
c'est sur cette cette différence que
l'on peut ce combat commun que l'on que
l'on retrouve si les talibans et czech
oui on a pas de débat à ce sujet c'est
vraiment un expert je veux distinguer
les différences entre les deux sens le
contredire montchrestien
c'est à dire que le taliban il a un
objectif dans dépendance ce qu'on voit
maintenant c'est une guerre
d'indépendance et ils ont gagné si elle
veut comme par marjorie 6 ha de terres
libère donc ils vont gouverner
d'ailleurs ils n'ont jamais gouverné
rien de trop l'objectif c'est gira de
global c'est le cas et donc ses
objectifs sont en désaccord dans ce nom
quand derrière celle ci commence à se
battre contre les talibans le
gouvernement d' en dépendant des
ministères les sociaux à des fins mais
pour l'instant c'est une croyance de
condamnant ils ont un ennemi en commune
les étrangères lene chiffre à 10 les
angles les infidèles les collaborateurs
et c'est comme un peu comme le fin de la
guerre d'algérie aux millions des
français sont quittés algeria ils sont
arrivés dans le sud de la france on a
une centaine 200000 quinquis ont
collaboré avec les américains et les
talibans peut chasser l'envahisseur
donc on peut pas s'attendre de ce que
vous dites est ce que les talibans mu
contre des shu on peut donc s'attendre à
d'autres d'autres attentats en tout cas
tant que les troupes étrangères ne sont
pas parties du territoire douglas est
qu'il y aura toujours des un conflit a
rien de signé notre ami d'abord à un
conflit géopolitique les talibans sur
nationaliste l'état islamique et
internationaliste mais il y aura
forcément des différences et donc vous
horaire il faut prévoir les talibans ont
déjà tué un besoin de le préciser un des
anciens leaders de l'état islamique dont
qui sont à à même de se poser il y aura
potentiellement une guerre fratricide et
c'est une des difficultés
auxquelles
donc le le gouvernement taliban
inclusif où minoritairement inclusif et
bien hors à se confronter c'est que il a
été radicale mais il trouve avec l'état
islamique plus radical que lui
donc la laisse y est je voudrais vous
poser une question sur l'opinion
publique américaine qui se montre est
largement en faveur d'un retrait des
troupes américaines
selon un sondage de politico et monique
consulter le soutien des américains a
chuté à 49 % contre 60 9 % au mois
d'avril cela va largement peser sur la
présidentielle de joe biden oui oui
parce que le duo breeden président
maintenant c'est une catastrophe mais
ses copains
70% des américaines en avril veulent
partir ils se tuent demandant une envie
qu'il soit content d'avoir tient le saut
stabilité c'est les américaines ne
trouve aucune entrée nationale d'y
rester
vaguement il y a une foi et de
terrorisme bien sûr ma soeur l'a quand
même donc dans un an les humains qu'elle
soit contente craquer entre temps ça
grignote
la popularité du duo made in qu'ils
veulent avec ce capital investi dans le
politique domestique et on termine avec
vous vers la respire je vais vous
laisser réagir ce que vient dire double
s y est
fondamentalement tout électorat vote en
fonction de sa situation nationale et
donc les états unis des stocks
américains neuner chaque pas à cette
règle si l'économie américaine va bien
et va de mieux en mieux et bien les
déboires où les difficultés extérieures
seront oubliées ainsi le chômage est à
trois et demi ou 4% seulement et bien
voilà vite dubaï donne ainsi le pouvoir
d'achat augmente et bejeweled hayden est
effectivement la page afghane sera
tourné pour les prochaines élections
présidentielles américaines merci
beaucoup à gérard vestiaire je rappelle
que vous êtes fondateurs du web magazine
le monde décrypté et merci à vous
douglas y est professeur de droit et
spécialiste de sciences politiques
américaines merci à vous merci